the Joe Rogan experience thanks for
coming back man I really appreciate it
this is a perfect time to talk to
someone like you about our food
we're in a very strange crisis now and
you just keep you're in time and time
again in the news how much ranchers and
farmers and people are really suffering
right now and how much folks who don't
have anything to do with that are now
forcing their their being forced to
understand the the importance of the
food supply chain and ranchers and
farmers and all the stuff that we've
taken for granted for quite a long time
now well they sure have and what's
interesting about it is the
juxtaposition between the I'll just call
it the industrial the more you know a
commercial industrial food sector versus
the sector that I'm in which is a a
local centric you know direct direct
sale branded product you know directly
from the farm the pandemic is the best
marketing strategy we've ever seen we're
having we're having the best season
we've ever had and and and and the same
thing was with farmers around the
country as I talked to them everyone
that's like us that that that did not go
into the supermarket system basically
that that's selling in our community and
they're in their region regionally
directly off the farm having the best
best year we've ever had it is the it is
the it's the industrial mega system
that's cracking and so for the first
time we're hearing talk of well maybe
maybe we need to add resiliency to
efficiency and so so yeah the the system
that's cracking there's plenty of food I
mean des plenty of food on farms being
produced but of course as you know milk
is being dumped pigs are being
euthanized the problem is not at the
farm level the problem is in the Chain
of Custody between the farmer and the
consumer and primarily in the in the the
large scale processing situation yeah
these large meat processing places that
they've been hit hard by the coronavirus
they have been I mean if you think about
it right now Joe probably in in the end
in the United States the only places
right now where every day thousands of
people come together in crowded
conditions are these big meat processing
plants I mean the offices are closed the
theaters are closed the convention
centers are closed and so the only place
where people are coming
shoulder-to-shoulder thousands every day
are in these mega processing facilities
Teresa and I my wife actually co-owned a
very small abattoir a slaughterhouse
community slaughterhouse we have 20
employees and and the difference is the
difference in the vulnerability in the
exposure and risk factor between our
little 20 person facility where we do
you know maybe 50 to 70 beeves a week
hundred hogs versus these mega plants
that have you know you say beeves beefs
like beef beefs yeah well I thought you
said beeves
there's no such word as beefs it's
Bebe's be EVs Oh Biebs no okay so the
plural of beef is not beefs its beeves
oh I always thought that beef was just
the meat I never thought I would have
sumed you would say cows well as a
farmer cows are our females who have had
calves that's a very as opposed to steer
years we would be cat or bulls which
would be intact males deer on a non
intact so as a farmer all this
nomenclature Israel you know it's normal
for you it's real like a theologian
teases out you know Presbyterians and
Methodists and and we just say well
they're Protestants you so so you know
we do we do it's a it's a small facility
and and you know it's been in business
for I don't know what 60 years or so
we've only Co
now for a little bit less than ten years
but but the difference because we do
stuff by hand workstations you know
these stainless-steel work tables are
what you know six seven eight feet wide
three feet to four feet deep and and
each one is a workstation and you've got
three guys out on a kill floor you got
two guys out in the you know the cryovac
room you've got four guys in the boning
room you got a guy over here running the
sausage stuffer or the you know the
grinder it's inherently small-scale
spread out completely different
environment than when you're having your
three thousand people in a cool damp
environment from and I don't want to get
into a rabbit trail discussion but but
frankly in these great great big plants
most of the workers are generally not
Americans they're they're they're coming
from other countries looking for you
know the American dream
and so they're living in crowded
conditions because they're trying to
save every penny to send home to get you
know uncle and aunt and other family
members here from Ethiopia Somalia you
know wherever it is and and so they're
there they're living in a house that we
would live for in a house they're living
you know 20 and they're eating poorly
they're in a they're in a stressful
they're there they're often separated
from their family there's just a lot of
stress in their lives and and and so
then you throw these big processing
facilities they're not they're not
eating well and it's just it's just an
incubator if you wanted to create an
incubator for a virus
there wouldn't be a better place where
as small facilities are inherently the
workers are spread out they tend to come
from the community they tend to be
career craft people rather than just you
know make this cut Mack yeah the average
poultry processing plant in our area
they say that every job can be learned
in 20 minutes hmm
so we're
at our plant we cross you know we we
cross do you know we cut me too wild and
then we go pack a wild and you're on the
cut floor and then you're you know
you're doing different things so it's a
real different environment and so these
big plants are very vulnerable and
that's why the recalls come from there
the you know the microbials come from
there I mean an average an average
fast-food hamburger has pieces of 600
animals in it
Wow when you get a hamburger from us
it's one animal you know so the just the
sheer whatever mixing you know so you
know for sure we don't know a lot about
this virus for every we're learning
every day and you know you got to kind
of take a little bit a great assault too
but one of the things we're certainly
learning is that there's an advantage
that there is a density factor a people
density factor like an urban rural you
know spreading out the whole social
distancing spreading out thing is seems
to be a valuable thing and so if we take
that into the food system wouldn't it be
an amazing thing if instead of having a
hundred and fifty to two hundred mega
processing facilities doing ninety-eight
percent of the nation's meat if instead
that were two hundred thousand
small-scale community-based ecologically
nested facilities
you know all around the countryside that
would be an incredibly resilient system
[Applause]